We're looking for the legendary Kevin Bacon
you're coming with us as a Christmas present
I'm through
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special review
I'll talk about how it sort of fits into Marvel
phase 4 Marvel phase five because technically
it's still part of Marvel phase four Ant-Man and
the Wasp Quantumania with Kang will be the first
Marvel Phase 5 project we'll start getting more
trailers for that soon too so if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos I'll do a full Easter eggs breakdown
post-credits scene video later this week after
they actually release it on Disney plus so be
sure to watch it when you get a chance it is meant
to be a prequel for Guardians of the Galaxy 3 set
after the events of Thor love and thunder so it's
after the Guardians have taken off and Thor's gone
on his way and gone through the adventure through
Thor 11 Thunder set later that same year during
the Christmas holiday about three years after
Avengers end game the basic premise is that after
they split with Thor they all went to different
distress signals Thor went to help Sif because
he recognized her and then the Guardians of the
Galaxy just went to other different distressed
signals because there were so many of them and
after a couple of months have gone by they're just
taking a break chilling out on this planet for the
holidays just resting the entire Vibe is based on
the Star Wars holiday special from 1978 if you've
never watched that you should at least watch a
little bit of it if you can make it through the
entire thing you're a total champ because it was
genuinely terrible all the Star Wars actors were
forced to perform in it at the time they said they
hated it after it happened George Lucas also hated
it so much that he tried to erase all knowledge of
it from the entire Earth it's only been in present
day with the Resurgence of all the newer Star Wars
stuff that people have been like hey remember that
funny Star Wars holiday special let's make fun of
that and bring it back so now sort of exists in
this really special place in the fandom like it
is a bit of a rite of passage if you're a hardcore
Star Wars fan Peter Quill is still super depressed
about what happened with Gamora during Avengers
end game he thought that she was dead but that she
came back from 2014 so he's trying to reunite with
this other version of Gamora even though she has
no connection to him she really only knows nebula
because she never went through those adventures
during the first Guardians in the second Guardians
movie and he's having his long dark night of the
soul that Thor was having at the beginning of
Thor love and thunder like Peter Quill gave him
the pep talk in Thor love and thunder now the
other Guardians are trying to cheer Peter Quill
up because of what happened with Gamora but the
whole thing about the Guardians of the Galaxy is
that they're meant to all be this ragtag group
of misfits from across the universe like even
though kraglan looks like a human Cracklin is not
meant to be a human Peter Quill is the only actual
human on the team James Gunn was very specific
about that that was like his whole reason for
not doing a version of Nova on Guardians of the
Galaxy so because all the other Guardians of the
Galaxy only know a little bit about human culture
what Peter Quill has told them and shown them like
the whole mixtape culture they know about 80s
music they know about 80s pop culture because
Peter Quill won't shut up about it that's why all
the Guardians of the Galaxy ships are named after
80s pop stars they discover the human custom of
Christmas they don't really understand what it
means but they think it'll cheer Peter Quill up so
they want to throw him a big Christmas celebration
so a lot of it is the Guardians trying to figure
out exactly what Christmas is then you have Drax
and mantis coming up with the idea that they're
going to bring someone of 80s culture from Earth
to help cheer Peter Quill up the legendary Kevin
Bacon they actually released the clip of that
maybe if we gave Peter a really wonderful
Christmas gift it would make him happy
kind of present something
special he will never forget
what about someone special what or the year
school has talked about one person more than any
other a legendary hero who has saved countless
lives we could give him the quilt as a present
so the whole idea there is they have no idea who
Kevin Bacon is they just think that Peter Quill
really really likes him and he's supposed to be
this legendary figure because Peter Quill won't
shut up about him obviously there's a whole bunch
of Easter eggs in using Kevin Bacon and James Gunn
said that he actually wrote him into the special
first then called him and Kevin Baker was like oh
hell yeah I'll be in your Christmas special but
that was years ago while they were still making
Guardians of the Galaxy 2 when they conceived
this Kevin feige said that the Guardians of the
Galaxy holiday special was the very first
Disney plus program that they conceived of
when they knew they were going to create Disney
Plus in a lot of the comedy of the special is
the Guardians of the Galaxy characters just not
really getting Christmas in general but trying
their damnedest to do the best Christmas ever to
help Peter Quill so like all the other Guardians
of the Galaxy movies the big theme is the family
coming together to celebrate this special event
even though they don't totally understand what it
means it is super funny but most of the comedy is
in the tone of all the other Guardians movies so
if you've seen any of the other Guardians movies
or you've seen the Guardians in Avengers Infinity
War Avengers endgame in Thor love and thunder
all their dialogue all the funny moments feel
like they could have been scenes in those other
movies so it's not like completely out of place
or completely out of tone there are a couple big
surprises there is a post credit scene so make
sure you do watch through the entire credits
no spoilers about what's in that if you do know
please don't post spoilers in the comments below
I will do like a completely separate video for all
that stuff later this week and obviously because
music is such a big part of all the Guardians of
the Galaxy movies and stories a big part of this
is the Christmas themed music that they bake
into it so what James Gunn did is he took the
Old 97's band and dressed them up as ravagers so
they're like characters in the special but they
perform an original Christmas song Kevin Bacon
also sings an original Christmas song during
the special there are a couple other big surprises
and character twists that I don't want to get into
because they're kind of spoilery but they do have
a brand new ship and it's called the Bowie like I
said all the Guardians of the Galaxy ships are
based on Big Pop Culture Stars when Peter Quill
was young during the 80s Chris Pratt was great as
Peter Quill I thought they were actually one of
the good things during Thor love and thunder like
a lot of people had complaints about Thor love and
thunder but the Guardians of the Galaxy themselves
were not one of those complaints they were fairly
consistent during that and that just continues
through this Drax and mantis were hilarious
obviously they have their big adventure trying to
steal Kevin Bacon from Earth and bring him back
if he didn't realize too one of the reasons why
they just don't get General situations in comedy
is because they're meant to be coded autistic
so it's not like Drax trying to be a dick to a
lot of other characters it's just him just not
totally understanding social situations and the
same with mantis because she grew up in isolation
do you think you can toss me over the gate if you
oh what are you doing tossing you over the gate
I didn't mean right that second also if it wasn't
clear during Guardians of the Galaxy 2 mantis
is Peter Quill's half-sister through ego the
whole idea is the ego of The Living Planet had
thousands of children all over the universe the
probably the most WTF montages they've had in
one of the Guardians of the Galaxy movies ego
getting it on with every different Race Across
the Universe mantis was just one of the children
that he had with one of these different races that
was useful enough that he didn't kill off because
of their abilities rocket was great always loved
Bradley Cooper coming back as Rocket he's going
to be one of the main characters during Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 like he's a big character during
this but he's a much bigger character to the plot
during Guardians 3. I've already done a Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 trailer video so I'll link this
at the end of this and down in the description
below Vin Diesel was great as sort of the teenage
version of Groot obviously he's grown up there's
a lot to talk about with Groot that I'll save
for my Easter eggs my spoilery videos the Chad
version of Groot Karen Gillen has been great as
nebula through all the movies but I feel like
since Avengers end game Avengers Infinity War
she's become a much much bigger character within
the scope of the Guardians of the Galaxy's story
she's probably had the biggest Arc of any of the
Guardians characters because she started out
being a really hardcore villain in the first
film really hoping she continues to come back as
a nebula in future Marvel projects after Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 because that's meant to be the
last movie with this version of the Guardians of
the Galaxy team Cracklin was also great if you
guys didn't realize he's James Gunn's brother
in real life he's done a bunch of stuff outside
of the Guardians of the Galaxy Marvel stuff but
he's also been a really big character because in
addition to playing craglin in the previous films
he's also been the body double for Rocket when
they're filming on said because Bradley Cooper
just comes in and does the voice later on so
he's been a fundamental part of the Guardians
of the Galaxy ever since the beginning ages that
ever since Guardians of the Galaxy 2 he's sort of
Taken yondu's spot on the team gotten yondu's
fin obviously he's wearing it during this one
of the biggest new characters during the special
obviously Cosmo the talking dog who's a big part
of the Guardians of the Galaxy comic books but
in the previous movies they just kind of used
her as an Easter egg level character the whole
idea she's based on like the Russian space dock
who was fired into space and wound up dying in
real life but in the Marvel Universe when that
happened Cosmo was bombarded with cosmic rays
wound up on nowhere and gained the ability to
talk so even though they didn't really include
any dialogue in the trailers for this you have
to just imagine a very chatty dog walking around
with rocket the reason why James Gunn said that
she wasn't a big character during Guardians of
the Galaxy one or two just because they already
had a talking tree in a talking raccoon and he
felt like adding her as a really big character
would have been too much too soon can't say enough
about the legendary Kevin Bacon during this he had
a lot of fun obviously he was a champ for agreeing
to do it there's so much that we can talk about
for his character just the idea that because he's
a real actor he made all these box Marvel movies
he was Sebastian Shaw he made the Footloose movie
like there's all this pop culture all these Easter
eggs and connections just by saying that the real
actor is an actual person inside the MCU it's like
Samuel L Jackson being Mace Windu in the Star Wars
movies but also Nick Fury like Spider-Man sees him
and says wait you're actually pretty similar to
that guy in the Star Wars movie I'll talk more
about that during my Easter egg video than the way
the Marvel directors The Producers talk about it's
just like a funny coincidence like oh you look
very similar to that actor Samuel L Jackson you
look very similar to that Kevin Bacon Marvel's
record with the one-off special presentation
events like werewolf by night has been 100 so
far like this is genuinely great but obviously
very different from the Werewolf By Night Special
Marvel does have plans to do a bunch more one-off
specials there's rumors about them now doing a
Silver Surfer special before the Fantastic Four
movie comes out in a couple years and also Ryan
Reynolds Just revealed that he made a Deadpool
Christmas movie before Fox bought Disney and
it was kind of lost in the shuffle so now I
actually think it'd be easy slam dunk for them to
release a Deadpool one-off Christmas special in
some future year I just did a big video about
that secret Deadpool Christmas movie so click
here to learn all about that and click here for
my full Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
breakdown Easter eggs and post-credits scene
I'll update the link as soon as I post that
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!